cortney's with us in Columbus Ohio hi
Courtney how are you I'm doing great mr.
Riley peace be with Jones is very
excited to talk to you
you too sir how can I help yes sir so um
I'm totally against debt including
mortgage debt so I have a couple
questions for you regarding mortgages
first um I'm a bit confused of why you
are accepting of mortgage debt and why
that's okay and I also wanted to know do
you see any issue with with me renting
the long term while saving for a house
that buyout rate number one usually when
I answer the question depending on how
much time I have when I'm talking about
it I explain to folks that I'm not okay
with mortgages I tolerate them and it's
the one kind of debt that I just don't
yell at you for the rest of it's just so
stupid you can't breathe that one eye
you know that one is out you can get
away with it and you can get it paid off
and have a long-term plan to get it
redone
I personally don't borrow money I often
say that on the show and so I don't have
a mortgage
we're building a 50 million dollar
office building right now that we are
building at the speed of cash and then
say and we've told the contractor we
told the newspaper when they want to do
a report on it that we're not you know
we're not building this thing unless we
have the cash or as we have the cash
that's a lot of money for a boy from
Antioch Tennessee by the way I'll just
tell you blows my mind and so it's kind
of like saving up to pay cash for a
house except plus a little and so you
know yeah what I what I rent if I were
in your shoes yeah cuz I don't borrow
money but now here's the thing you rent
the cheapest possible thing you can
because every dollar you spend on rents
not a dollar you're saving for the house
you work an extra job you go crazy and I
want you to pay cash for your first
little ol house and get get get a house
that's even if it's not much if you a
house quick I mean like three five years
I'm not talking about ten fifteen twenty
years saving up do it in three to five
years you can do it a guy like you who's
got convictions like this you can do it
and you call me back and I'll break on
you this is the Dave Ramsey show